lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
revisar algo de lo cual ya hemos hablado
con anterioridad y espero que esto te
permita desarrollar la intuición de por
qué dividimos entre n menos 1 si lo que
deseamos es tener un estimador in
sesgado de la varianza poblacional
cuando estamos calculando la varianza
muestral
consideremos entonces una población
supongamos que esta es la población y es
una población de tamaño n mayúscula y
también tenemos una muestra de esa
población una muestra de esa población
cuyo tamaño es n minúscula es decir
tenemos n datos consideremos ahora todos
los parámetros y estadísticos con los
que hemos venido trabajando el primero
es el concepto de la media la media si
estamos tratando de calcular la media
para la población va a ser esta un
parámetro o un estadístico bueno si
estamos tratando de calcular la media
para la población estamos calculando un
parámetro estamos calculando un
parámetro déjame escribir esto por aquí
a la población para la población estamos
calculando un parámetro para la
población es parámetro si lo estamos
calculando para la muestra para la
muestra estamos calculando el
estadístico estadístico entonces como
calculamos la media para la población
bien para empezar lo denotamos con la
letra griega new y básicamente tomamos
todos los datos en nuestra población
tomamos la suma de todos los datos
empezando con el primer dato y
terminando con el enésimo dato así que
todos y cada uno de los datos los
sumamos empezamos con el dato x 1 x 2
así hasta llegamos al x n y dividimos
esta suma entre el número total de datos
n ahora cómo calculamos la media de la
muestra bien para la media muestral
hacemos algo similar pero ahora para la
muestra la denotamos con una x con una
raya encima y se le conoce como x raya
para calcular esta tomamos todos los
puntos de la muestra por lo cual el
límite superior de la suma es
n minúscula los sumamos sumamos todos
los valores de nuestra muestra y lo
dividimos entre el número de datos que
se tiene en la muestra ahora el otro
valor que vamos a intentar calcular para
la población por lo cual va a ser un
parámetro y que también vamos a
calcularlo para la muestra con un
estimado del valor de la población es la
varianza la cual es una medida de
dispersión o una medida de que tanto
varían los datos con respecto a la media
escribamos la varianza la varianza y
como denotamos y calculamos la varianza
para una población bien para la
población decimos que la varianza y
vamos a usar la letra griega sigma
elevado al cuadrado y éste es igual
podemos considerar la varianza como el
promedio de las distancias al cuadrado
con respecto a la media poblacional y lo
que hacemos es para cada dato empezando
desde 1 y acabando en n para cada dato
le vamos a restar la media le vamos a
restar la media por lo cual tendría que
haber calculado la media primero vamos a
ver que hay otra manera de hacerlo
directamente pero bueno lo más
fácil es calcular primero la media y a
partir de ahí obtener este valor
entonces a cada dato le restamos el
valor de la media lo elevamos al
cuadrado elevamos al cuadro la
diferencia hacemos la suma y la
dividimos entre el número total de datos
veamos ahora la parte interesante la
varianza de la muestra hay varias
maneras cuando la gente habla de
varianza muestral existen varias maneras
herramientas software para calcular esta
varianza muestral una manera es la
varianza de la muestra sesgada el
estimador sesgado de la varianza
poblacional el cual se denota por una
ese subíndice n y como calculamos es
estimador sesgado de la varianza
poblacional bueno vamos a hacerlo de
manera muy similar a como lo hicimos
aquí pero ahora lo haremos para la
muestra y no para la población para cada
valor para cada valor de la muestra
vamos a restarle la media muestral
la media muestral la vamos elevada al
cuadrado vamos a hacer la suma de esos
valores y luego se divide entre el
tamaño de la muestra pero como ya
mencionamos en el último vídeo como
encontraríamos cuál sería nuestro mejor
estimador en sesgado de la varianza
poblacional estamos tratando de
encontrar un estimador in sesgado de la
varianza poblacional bien en el vídeo
pasado mencionamos que si tú querías
calcular un estimador in sesgado y en
este vídeo espero darte el sentido
intuitivo de por qué esto es así para el
estimador in sesgado tomaremos cada uno
de los valores le restamos la media
elevaremos la diferencia al cuadrado
sumaremos las diferencias pero en vez de
dividir la suma entre n la dividiremos
entre n menos 1 estamos dividiendo entre
un número que es menor es un número
menor por lo cual este estimador el
estimador de la varianza muestral es un
número que es mayor este número es mayor
con respecto a este que es
menor este valor se conoce como el
estimador in sesgado el estimador y
sesgado y este aquí es el estimador
sesgado el estimador sesgado cuando la
gente escribe esto para denotar la
varianza de la muestra sería bueno que
precisarán a cuál de los dos refieren
pero pero si tienes que adivinar y no
hay información adicional muy
probablemente se están refiriendo al
estimador insertado de la varianza para
el cual se tiene que dividir entre n
menos uno pero pensemos porque este
estimador es sesgado y porque deseamos
un valor del estimador que es un número
mayor y quizás en un futuro te
presentará un programa por computadora
que nos haga comprender mejor por qué el
dividir entre n menos 1 nos da una mejor
estimación del valor real de la varianza
poblacional imaginemos ahora todos los
datos de la población todos los datos de
la población y los voy a graficar en la
recta numérica este es una recta
numérica y aquí voy a poner los datos de
mi población aquí tenemos un valor aquí
hay otro valor otro valor aquí hay más
datos
aquí tenemos
otro valor aquí tenemos más datos más
datos por aquí más datos por acá los
puede distribuir como yo quiera aquí
simplemente tenemos datos sobre la recta
numérica supongamos que toma una muestra
de esto este es toda mi población que
tiene veamos cuántos valores 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 valores tenemos así
que en este caso cuánto vale n mayúscula
n mayúscula es igual a 14 supongamos que
toma una muestra en este caso mi muestra
sería digamos de tamaño n minúscula
igual a 3 podría tomar bueno antes de
que hagamos eso
pensemos dónde se ubicaría
aproximadamente la media de esta
población no lo va a calcular pero
podemos decir que aproximadamente se
ubicaría aquí aquí ubicaríamos
aproximadamente el valor real del
parámetro media de la población pensemos
ahora qué ocurre cuando tomamos una
muestra aunque esto es válido para
cualquier tamaño de muestra
voy a hacerlo para una muestra pequeña
simplemente para desarrollar el aspecto
intuitivo del asunto
supongamos entonces que tomamos una
muestra de tamaño
n igual a 3 existe cierta posibilidad
que al tomar una muestra de tamaño 3
suceda que seleccionamos la muestra de
tal manera que la media de la población
se ubica muy cerca de la media de la
muestra así por ejemplo seleccionamos
este punto este punto este otro punto
podemos imaginar en una aproximación
visual que la media muestra 'la se ubica
bastante cerca de la media poblacional
pero también es posible que cuando tomé
mi muestra
tome este valor este valor y este valor
y la clave aquí es saber que cuando
tomas una muestra la media de la muestra
se va ubicar entre los valores de la
muestra así es que hay la posibilidad de
que cuando tomes una muestra la media de
la muestra se ubica alejada de la media
poblacional así que en este caso y
simplemente para darte la intuición la
media la muestra pudiera estar ubicada
digamos por aquí por ahí ubicamos la
media y si fuéramos a calcular la
distancia de cada uno de los puntos con
respecto a la media de la muestra así
que tomarías esta distancia esta
distancia de acá luego lo llevarías al
cuadrado y cuando lo divides entre el
número de puntos basta tener una
estimación de la varianza
mucho menor al valor real de la varianza
que se tiene con respecto a la media
poblacional aquí puedes ver que estos
valores están mucho más alejados ahora
no siempre va a estar el valor de la
media poblacional fuera de la muestra
pero es posible que esto suceda así que
en general si simplemente tomas tus
puntos encuentra la distancia al
cuadrado con respecto a la media
muestral la cual siempre va a estar
entre esos puntos aún así la media
poblacional podría estar fuera de esos
puntos o podrías tener un extremo de
dónde se ubican tus datos de cualquier
manera es muy probable que estés
subestimando el valor real de la
varianza poblacional así es que con este
valor vas a estar subestimando
subestimando la varianza poblacional por
lo cual resulta que si en vez de dividir
entre n dividimos entre n menos uno
tendremos un valor de la varianza
muestral que es ligeramente mayor y que
resulta ser una estimación in sesgada en
un próximo vídeo voy a generar una
simulación por computadora a través del
cual nos convenzamos aún más del por qué
esta estimación es mucho mejor que esta
estimación para la varianza poblacional